-Performing "Code" and "54321,"
once again, Offset!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I don't play no games.
Hey!
♪ Staring at my wristopher ♪
♪ Yeah, it blew a kiss at her ♪
♪ Water diamond Christopher ♪
♪ Keep your kids from mystical ♪
♪ Smoke, what's
your temperature? ♪
♪ Better not at or mention 'em ♪
♪ Get you whacked intentional ♪
♪ We send hits,
ain't missing 'em ♪
♪ Bought another Cullinan ♪
♪ Bulletproof like government ♪
♪ Grew up with my brother dem ♪
♪ Big bro always hustling ♪
♪ Since my brother got killed,
it ain't no fight ♪
♪ It ain't no tussling ♪
♪ Fighting in the courthouse
for my kids ♪
♪ I need some custody ♪
♪ Fake, they counterfeit ♪
♪ Money boost my confidence ♪
♪ Hating that's unfortunate ♪
♪ I get checks, I'm corporate ♪
♪ White diamonds
like porcelain ♪
♪ You can't call yourself rich
if you do not own no mortgages ♪
♪ Sometimes when I'm home,
I feel alone ♪
♪ Like I'm an orphanage ♪
♪ When it's cold outside,
you better, hey ♪
♪ She got so much mileage,
she tryna work one on me ♪
♪ I had so much knowledge,
I had to get out the streets ♪
♪ I didn't graduate college ♪
♪ Black ceramic AP ♪
White ceramic AP ♪
♪ That's 400 a piece ♪
♪ If I front, that's a fee ♪
♪ When I pulled out
the chopper ♪
♪ He act like
he couldn't speak ♪
♪ I been focused on me ♪
♪ 100 racks in the brief ♪
♪ I had shackles on feet ♪
♪ I adapt in the streets ♪
♪ I drip sauce in my sleep ♪
♪ Baddest bitch on my arm ♪
♪ Wish they was me ♪
♪ I'mma do...wrong ♪
♪ They was doubting on me,
let's go ♪
♪ Money boost my confidence ♪
♪ Hating that's unfortunate ♪
♪ I get checks, I'm corporate ♪
♪ White diamonds
like porcelain ♪
♪ You can't call yourself rich
if you do not own no mortgages ♪
♪ Sometimes when I'm home,
I feel alone ♪
♪ Like it's an orphanage ♪
♪ When it's cold outside,
you better grip on your heat ♪
♪ She got so much mileage,
she tryna work one on me ♪
♪ I had to get out the streets ♪
♪ Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo ♪
♪ Let's go ♪
♪ Panoramic, I can see
right through it ♪
♪ Smokin' on cookie,
it's gas manure ♪
♪ Threw 50 racks in a lure ♪
♪ Know we gon' run with the pack
like a wolf ♪
♪ Thug life on me
like I'm Tupac Shakur ♪
♪ 35K for the seats
on the floor ♪
♪ Yes, I'm the wave
but don't got a shore ♪
♪ Starin' at me but I ♪
♪ Almost had crashed the 'Rari ♪
♪ Jump off the rope
like Jeff Hardy ♪
♪ Be broke and be ready to ♪
♪ Nike mask on, man,
I'm feelin' like Marty ♪
♪ 'Scuse me,
don't you be walkin' ♪
♪ Don't got no money
so you shouldn't be talkin' ♪
♪ DM'ing me, but you know
I ain't talkin' ♪
♪ My...find out, she gon' kill
'em, white chalk 'em ♪
♪ Shh ♪
♪ It's a dead man ♪
♪ Rocks on my neck like
the Flintstone, I'm Bam Bam ♪
♪ Ran up them M's and I bought
me the lamb ♪
♪ She on my,
want a pic, she a fan-fan ♪
♪ Postin' these racks but I know
it's a scam ♪
♪ Don't cuff a,
I'm not selfish, I share 'em ♪
♪ Elliot pink diamonds
lookin' like Cam ♪
♪ He actin' tough but he sweeter
than yams ♪
♪ Two bitches in a Rolls Ghost
and it scare 'em ♪
♪ I collect shoes and I don't
even wear 'em ♪
♪ 25 million I get ♪
♪ Hello ♪
♪ I want that, I like thick with
them lil' bitty ♪
♪ I like bitches rich and they
know how to get it ♪
♪ Come from the dark my wrist
and neck is litted ♪
♪ Never quit it, you was hatin',
wait in line ♪
♪ Was hatin', wait in line ♪
♪ Ew, that's nasty,
can't catch me ♪
♪ I'm in the Lambo, this ♪
♪ This a wide body
and the rims look ♪
♪ How did this happen? ♪
♪ Ain't eatin' and they ♪
♪ Fresh to death
like I jumped out a casket ♪
♪ Before the COVID-19,
we was maskin' ♪
♪ When I say spin it,
that mean I'mma shoot ♪
♪ Hop out the Maybach and Prada
my boot ♪
♪ 30 mill plus
and I don't wear a suit ♪
♪ Bust like a gusher,
you play with my group ♪
♪ Singin' like Usher,
this chopper a fool ♪
♪ Hustler customers ♪
♪ Louis V ♪
♪ I'm outta here ♪
♪ Five, four, three, two, one ♪
♪ Takeoff, touch my brother,
pull a gun ♪
♪ Woo, woo, woo ♪
♪ Five, four, three, two, one ♪
♪ Woo, woo, woo, woo,
woo, woo, woo ♪
♪ Five, four, three, two, one ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]